[Musique]
quoi
allez
yahoo
[Musique]
k
et de faire passer la part
[Musique]
voilà
ouais
kabato monter dans le bateau
[Musique]
non
mantei
voilà
[Musique]
allez
j'arrive pas à viser les bouche-trous va
me chercher le fusil à lunette bill ex
ante
[Musique]
je vais me faire je vais prendre pour
fusil
[Musique]
c'est peut-être un mauvais présage c'est
ça se trouve ils portent malheur ou je
sais pas quoi
on n'a jamais vu de ses couleurs il faut
que je dire maintenant s'ils ont un
autre le fera et c'est ce fumier qui
deviendra célèbre dans tout le pays et
sneijder nous a pas payé pour rien je
t'assure moi c'est pas une bonne idée
moi ce que je croise exige le tir pas
maintenant tu reviendras plus tard pour
me voler le trophée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous merci dose leur fait pas en
rien pourrais faire d'autre à
photographier doit parler à faire on
revient très vite
je vous félicite grâce à vous monsieur
moore à cet endroit va rentrer dans
l'histoire
il faut que je vous présente le russe
c'est lui qui a pisté le bison blanc
solide gaillard
vous l'avez dit venez à l'intérieur bien
des projets
c'est une sacrée somme pour avoir pisté
un animal que derrière ou d'un petit
verre sneijder city texas serait un joli
nom de ville
il pourrait être chargé de transporter
votre whisky à granby confié sa part qu
il s est risqué g12 cruchon d'autrui du
fait maison
la meilleure du texas vous pouvez tout
chargé dans le bateau ouais parfait
jeffrey prévenir leur donne il te
retrouvera en bord de la rivière dans
trois jours et tu reviendras avec le
paiement mais voilà c'est ce sera pour
le transport encore une belle somme
messieurs allons-y
si ça ne gêne pas j'aimerais que les
gens croient que c'est avec le fusil de
mon père que je les ai
miramar clède chargé le whisky
barclays est ici charles le whisky dans
le mato la pauvre les autres mais carter
fait la place trop chaud devant
c'est concret merci reculer le recul est
encore un peu laisse-moi champs les
précieux à parfait ne bouge plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et seigneur tout ça ça me rappelle qu'il
faudrait que je me confesse ouais ça
aurait de bonnes raisons de le faire
je pense pas avoir vu une aussi jolie
fille depuis la fois où j'ai vu ta soeur
à spokane l'oeuvre de toute une vie
ce charlie m'a tout pris qu'ils soient
maudits lui sont associées couleurs je
veux plus
vous lui fassiez pays nous réclamons
pense ma fille si on y arrive sans que
le shérif rapplique ce sera pas cher
c'est juste une balle attiré bague mais
il y aura un prix à payer
oui les passagers
on essaiera d'éviter que ça vous coûte
cher que ce soit clair si vous tirez en
ville ce sera deux fois plus c'est
d'accord
allez en route pour dallas les gars je
suis désolé pour vous deux filles
deux mille dollars pour champagne
charles ix hosting
[Musique]
gala il a sacré en ouvrant une bouteille
d'eau ici j'ai la rage de dents j'ai mal
à en crever s'il vous plaît je peux
avoir une bouteille de whisky et
sylviane du connemara ce sera encore
mieux dieu vous bénisse très cher et
puisque c'est que la térébenthine
mais qu'est ce que vous faites arrêter
vous n'allez pas en boire j'ai juste
voulu vous faire une farce
j'espère qu'on finira jamais vous savez
il ya un dentiste dans cette ville ouais
mais je crois que ces dentistes sont
juste bons à nous mentir ianu déplumé et
je tiens pas à me faire avoir
j'avais trop mal pour me demander mon
nom moi c'est vrai
pardonnez moi vous êtes catherine bon eh
bien je vous offrir en mer dr catherine
les dames ne boivent pas du whisky idée
séduisante mais tu mangeras bon écoute
jim le docteur six gars n'habite pas
très loin d'ici et je suis persuadé
qu'il réussira à calmer la douleur si tu
veux je t'accompagne chili tu sais être
persuasive
juste le temps de payer au niveau après
toi je vous remercie pas si on allait
plutôt passer un moment dans ma chambre
d'hôtel je ne veux pas qu'à rage de
dents vienne gâcher notre dîner au
restaurant
ah oui on dîne ensemble ce soir à moins
que tu en est une autre invitée je te
donne rendez vous aux saint charles dans
deux petits tard tim thaler docteur du
titien jaune et noir nike
il ya quelqu'un monsieur docteur sigas
epa est parti pour un mois
ouais j'sais pas quoi [ __ ] c'est par
une prothèse à nos ruptures de stocks
non je vais garder mes dents ça ira
alors il est parti vous dites je crains
oui vous êtes dentiste aussi je suis le
dr alizés c'est ce qu'il ya de marquer
sur l'enseigne non j'aime donc tu me
lance docteur ge souffre le martyre là
et bien
asseyez-vous j'arrive juste le temps de
l'équiper
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites vous allez
vous sourit non ça c'est pour vous et je
suis sûr que vous en redemanderez
les flammes de l'enfer mêlée à l'eau
purificatrice du paradis bon c'est quoi
maintenant greg grecque quelle est votre
tolérance à la souffrance quoi peu
importe d'où vrai 13 $ et 14 cents
[Musique]
elle a l'air ancien cette montre
souvenir de mon irlande bien aimé c'est
tout ce qui me reste d'elle elle est
jolie taden ça va bah parker que
j'arrive plus à mâcher j'ai plus
l'impression d'avoir un clou planté à
l'intérieur je sais que tout cet argent
ne vient pas des chemins de fer n'ont
pas tous mais en grosse partie il ya de
l'argent que j'ai gagné honnêtement a
nettement
j'ai volé des tas de trucs quand j'étais
plus jeune m'arrive encore de la gnôle
j'en ai volé à boston et quand j'étais
au tennessee en réalité
j'aime parce que j'étais avant mais j'ai
jamais rien connu d'autre personne aimée
voleurs six mois y en a un que j'adore
pourquoi tu te balades avec un flingue
au donne moi ça je te les dix dallas est
une ville dangereuse et moi je suis une
dame
comment tu veux que je crois ça après la
nuit qu'on a passé tu voulais dire
maintenant j'avais mal autant hier
[Musique]
puis
arrête de m'embrasser pop et j'ai
seulement reposer
tu sais j'ai rien à faire aujourd'hui tu
pourrais peut-être m'apprendre à tirer
au pistolet tu sais tirer au pistolet
j'ai 28 ans et j'ai encore jamais tiré
au pistolet je peux peut-être à prendre
une ou deux choses mais pour l'instant
j'ai rendez vous avec quelqu'un qu'on se
verra au saloon ce soir quoi tes prises
toute la journée pas toute la journée
s'était dit qu'on se retrouvait ce soir
au saloon près de l'orchestré pour faire
un brin de toilette
je viendrai embrassés avant de partir et
tu as oublié temps libre à cheveux
je récupérerai martin s est dormir
[Musique]
chérie
ce bon vieux mari whisky comme
d'habitude il y aurait pas ici quelqu'un
qui s'appelle champagne charles austin
ok la mi mai
c'est bon les gars il est là
[Musique]
toi et moi on entrera les premiers vous
deux vous attendait le signal
nos erreurs ouais tu le couvre ouais tu
me prêtes ton pistolet non je ferais
quoi si jamais je me retrouve face à lui
mais moi si j'ai plus munitions tuent et
lance ton flingue dans la gueule ou tu
pries le ciel de t'envoyer des
cartouches tower chacun garde son
histoire
j'étais [ __ ] m'inquiète pas on les
plombs bras si certains derrière il se
dira toujours par derrière vous rester
là jusqu'à mon signal c'est clair
on était prêts
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
alors tu râlais données ratissé ce soir
c'est l'équipe qui était droite celui
qui élève est
c'est le parent de trisha n'ont soit pas
grossier tchèque a pris 7 et charlie je
suis pas un tricheur et apporte la bête
sérieux steam je paye verges contre mon
argent charlie il calme charlie que dans
ton bar ici pas dans la rue si tu
continues à te [ __ ] de moi avec des
petites remarques je te fait avaler
disco espèce de bata à ton haleine et si
puantes que ça pique les arcs en date et
pas viens me les faire avaler charlie
adam
c'était le signal symbole invite le
savoir tu causes beaucoup mais après y'a
plus personne est il doit savoir qu'il
ya une prime sur la tête de johnny ne
cache pas derrière cette dame charlie on
a un compte à régler
on attend kutcher nice fasse descendre
et on récupère le corps après mon
l'anthracnose gatti ses pertes charlie
[Musique]
rappaz
vous recherchez le shérif bright falls
et ipad
revient tout de suite j'espère et puis
merde tower va voir ce qu'il ya dans la
classe avec plaisir mais tel n'a été
qu'un seul bouc ont fait pas d'album
vous brûlerez en aucun cas j'ai donc je
m'énerve c'est jour de paix où il est
elle prend pas mal aller je suis pas un
voleur
[Applaudissements]
tu travailles pour moitié
je sais charest ou des technos charlie
austin chauray n'arriverait pas de tirer
dans la main même si tu la mettais
devant qu'à nantes on colle poids vos
attentes
ainsi paris
c'est pas grave charli mois journée
chargée ça aux îles après dégâts et
quand on a fini de compter les billets
fille lors il va récupérer les chevaux
well givet à quoi vous jouez messieurs
et bien la tête de ce cher charlie
austin vaut une fortune pour noctua et
en attendant de la récupérer on se paye
sur leur selle ne sont pas une sorte à
quand un genre de pourboire du si oui
oui je crois c'est bien où elle fait le
tour par derrière tu veux aider que tu
retrouves charli tu le trouves de plomb
a pigé non personne naturelle patron
hu
un krach bien mais des grecs non
merde quoi catherine mais qu'est ce que
tu fais on en parlera plus tard toi il
émarge rendez vous pour les motards
tower
03/06 si vous posez pas mozart mais
qu'est ce que tu apprends [ __ ] plombe
moi ça va je tue personne
il faut pas qu'on restera des 11 tirs je
veux pas laisser dans la rue variable
moi que tu as la bataille ragaine moi tu
mens tu es tu m'as menti depuis le début
je suis désolé mais quand on est à
l'essai à les devs les mains celui-là
est armé arrêté les prenez nos âmes
alors vous cherchez temps les austin et
ben vous l'avez trouvé chariot ce titre
c'est pas toi c'est tout comme il a plus
de mal on se casse
coenen huther
[Musique]
il
oui je sais pas
[Musique]
voilà
tiens
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'on aille se planquer dans la forêt
faut réussir à pas les semis
intelligence manger rien fait d'illégal
pourquoi je me cache la même toit je
m'arrêterai pas alors si tu veux sauter
surtout ne gêne pas j'étais le premier
titre
ça plus vite regarde pas physique ça
prouve au nom
non merde
où en serait on n'y arrivera jamais mais
qu'est ce que tu fous le shérif doit pas
être loin derrière
il
je vois une lumière c'est par ici le
fuyard au galop si tu veux tu peux venir
mais si tu viens ma une boîte des
centres de là haut oui
[Musique]
alors
sortait bien bande de lâches âgées
aucune arme
montrez-vous tu veux bien calmé et a
battu les chevaux abattus les chevaux tu
dis t'es dingue qui ce qui t'a pris on
se serait fait repérer si on était
entrée en ville sur des chevaux qui
porte la marque de quelqu'un d'autre
on n'est pas tout à fait en ville au cas
où tu aurais pas remarqué la ce fleuve
celle brazos et une fois que tu le
traverse
tu arrives à g de riz tu veux que je te
dise ton pote qui est à g de riz il
vaudrait mieux qu'ils nous trouvent un
bon moyen de se remplir les poches parce
que je tue pas pour de l'argent mais
j'ai tué personne moi et ta bande est là
tu personnes peut-être j'y étais pour
rien moi j'ai pas tiré écoute je
garantis pas que ce vieil ami nous
couvrir adore mais si tu repars à dallas
aura beaucoup de mal à les convaincre de
pâtes envoyé à la potence j'ai pas
encore réussi à comprendre la totalité
de ce qui s'est passé à dallas ce qui
est sûr c'est que je dois récupérer mon
pognon je dois absolument récupérer je
veux pas de décourager mais tu sais
comme moi on verra jamais la couleur
allez les bleus quand va falloir
traverser à la nage
pas question ça veut dire quoi ça en de
question que je traverse
mais si tu traverses pas il faudra que
tu fasses un détour tu sais combien
d'heure de marche ca fait il ya encore
deux minutes j'avais un cheval je te dis
qu'une fois en ville mon pote benson ne
trouvera des chevaux désarmer tout ce
qu'il faudra ta question je traversais
pas toi tu sais pas nager
le fils de [ __ ] de voleurs irlandais tu
sais pas nager à vous je sais pas moi
d'accord je t'attends ville mais
voudrait mieux pour toi qu'on puisse se
faire de l'argent et vite
moi je vais y aller mettre à l'eau bon
d'accord j'avoue je sais pas nager
j'essaie de m'accrocher à toi
ouais
et moi je sais de nager ouais les dix
leurs concitoyens halim jalbaud une
seule ride
[Applaudissements]
mais écarte toi allez l'amène au ray
pour le refuser
[Applaudissements]
c'est là tu leur attention jeunes
interrompt jamais un homme qui joue au
bowling concentre toi je te dollars sur
toi je tends métiers de l'art est ravi
tu nous fait perdre notre argent durée
d'artois ont rien à leus je me laisserai
bien tenter par une de vos citations je
vous attends de pied ferme avec votre
shakespeare trek espèces de manchots 14
et j'en ai une
et comme ils ont su le vaillant je les
admirais mais comme il fut ambitieux je
les cuis jules césar acte iii trop
facile
bien joué démolir le portrait de jeumont
et et moi j'aurais aimé poursuivre mais
j'ai du travail au bar dont j'aurai
besoin d'être d'ailleurs quel bordel de
dieu
le jeu de bowling aura portes closes
pour le restant de la journée
sachez que je ne tolérerai jamais qu'on
s'entretue pour des paris aux sags ma
propriété fait ce en dehors de la ville
pourriez-vous dire à steel works de
faire le ménage rapidement entendu je
passerai au saloon dans la soirée
amusant non ces deux gars étaient de la
même équipe
je t'attends au barclays
[Musique]
voici
pas ces gens par dessus alors jeté jaune
à toit souple et je te dire si on songe
à boma guy beaucoup de me faire mal de
chair peut plus bouger
tu peux vous aider que veux tu que je
fasse rien n'inquiète pas ça va aller et
je le soutiens que ça va passer
enfin pas vous m'avez dégueulasse et ma
devanture est une honte de toi de
l'entrée thompson pousse toi de là et
qui va nettoyer c'est sa lancée ce n'est
toi oh non non
maggie pas plutôt acheter de beaux
habits pour fêter son anniversaire
à leszno ne t'en fais pas de jeunes ils
vont soigner ton bras excuse moi
excuse moi de mangas c'est un sens à
l'existence
on y va pour marcher attention à ta tête
ça va aller john salut maggie t'as vu
j'ai des oiseaux du tennis si tu veux
les toucher à d'avoir ce merdier
je suis obligé de serrer fort désolé
oui je ne vous voit pas souvent en ville
comment ça va on fait c'est qu'à ses
bras il a fait une mauvaise chute
ne craignez rien donc but ce n'est pas
de ces chaman indien c'est un docteur
hautement qualifiés je vous ai pas
demandé de venir gordon ce bâtiment
m'appartient je suis juste passé
chercher le loyer de notre cher docteur
ce sera très longue à guérir
je n'ai rien pour la douleur en ce
moment mais je peux lui donner un peu de
lausanne à ma wii ça ira si tu essaies
de te redresser sinon vous êtes contents
des chevaux moon
j'ai justement de quoi voulez payer
j'attends juste lavoine que vous m'aviez
promise il me faudrait alors j'ai une
idée
vous n'avez qu'à emmené kelly il vous
aidera à charger comprenez que votre
fils est inapte au travail vous
remercier
nous reviendrons en ville après demain
et je vous donnerai ce que tu dois
subordonne tout un travail au saloon ce
soir pour l'instant tu t'occupes du
transport tu reviendras en ville dans la
soirée au un moune sécher qui ne se
passe pas un jour sans que je ne pleure
la tragique disparition de votre femme
ne vous avisez plus jamais de parler de
ma femme tout donné
tu vas devoir garder ton bras en écharpe
d'accord c'est important allez la
fracture était net mais il faudra
attendre longtemps avant de te servir de
ton bras tu entendu un wade à tabac
merci docteur je n'ai pas oublié ce que
vous avez fait pour moi jonas aller aux
voix set partout
[Musique]
on
je peux vous renseigner c'est pourquoi
elle est magnifique et les beaucoup trop
cher pour une fille comme vous c'est une
robe qui viennent new york
je fais que l'admirer cet homme a été
tué par les indiens juste à la sortie de
la ville
alors vous voudrez bien excuser la
politique de la maison à savoir ne
jamais vendre d'articles sauvage ou au
sang mêlé
madame abigail peterson vous tombait à
point très cher j'ai reçu la dentelle
que vous m'avez commande et vous allez
l'adorer
[Musique]
je
ouais maggie tu peux lui faire boire ça
avec un peu de lait sucré ouais tu dois
pas rentrer en ville alors que les
derniers sacs dans la grange et matin
[Musique]
et
il n'y a pas eu d'orage aujourd'hui et
vous semblez assez malin pour ne pas
prendre de bain tous les billets mais il
doit y avoir une explication
je vous offre le premier verre c'est
très gentil alors pas du tout ça me
permet de travailler comme shakespeare
l'a écrit des enfants si précoce et si
sage dit on ne vivent pas mon temps bon
je vais faire celui qui a compris santé
sorte et ça fait du bien par où ça passe
un autre je suppose seulement 2
désolé l'ami on peut pas se permettre de
régler le barman non je vous l'offre
aussi c'est pour moi la dernière
bouteille de whisky préférait de gordon
dieu seul sait d'où ça vient mais encore
jamais vu avec un barman
comme vous le voyez messieurs nous ne
sommes pas débordés ici un et je me sens
un peu dépressif il faut que je me
soigne
on cherche un de mes amis bill benson
robert bill benson y vit ici
eh ben dis donc je crois qu'ils m'ont
froid la ville benson
les morts enterrés au cimetière
je vous dis amen pour 500 oui très drôle
l'ennui c'est que j'ai du mal à croire
mais j'apprécie l'offre on va devoir
trouver des chevaux pendant qu'on est en
ville alors là je crois que je tombe à
pic
pourquoi t'es tu es un cheval toi un
homme peut sourire et n'être qu'un
scélérat vous savez bien que gordon à
tous que ces messieurs peuvent désirer
le jeune kelly est un boubou cris les
débrouillards il devrait pouvoir vous
trouvez tout ce qu'il vous faut vous
ressert un autre vers la matinée les
étudiants alors tu dis que tu as des
chevaux c'est vrai
ggd chevaux bien sûr à 20 oui en réalité
ici ils sont pas vraiment un mois et
attend de partir si on n'a pas de temps
à perdre avec des conneries petit petit
cause toujours
vous avez des problèmes j'ai les
solutions
[Musique]
john john vite les deux tempêtes
je vais pas vous mentir john cette
potion a un goût horrible j'avais la
vallée d'une très pur
kelly tu sors d'ici toi aussi tu joues
tu sors bien entendu tu sors en une
heure il a perdu plusieurs fois
connaissance
john je suis là
seigneur vous êtes aussi pâle qu'un
fantôme remarque amusante parce que
c'est ce que j'ai l'impression d'être
depuis très longtemps je peux faire
quelque chose pour vous euh je voudrais
que vous vous asseyez ici
donc vous pouvez nous laisser un moment
oui je serai pas bien loin
je voudrais que vous fassiez quelque
chose pour moi je suis d'accord mais
pour l'instant vous feriez mieux de vous
reposer dogues bates dit que je ne
passerais probablement pas la nuit
je veux me confesser devant dieu et
devant un homme en qui j'ai confiance
j'ai peur de ne pas bien comprendre 1865
théâtre ford à washington
je suis entré discrètement dans la loge
du président des états unis d'amérique
j'ai pointé un pistolet sur la base de
son crâne et j appuyé sur la détente à
bout portant
ensuite j'ai fui en virginie par la
grâce de dieu je leur ait échappé et
j'ai vécu comme un rat depuis ce jour là
qu'est ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise
je ne vous demande pas de dire quelque
chose henry je veux que vous sachiez que
mon nom et patrizia télex mon nom est
john booth l'assassin d'abraham lincoln
écoutez john
vous êtes malade
il faut vous reposer je sais que ça a
l'air à saint c'est qu'il n'y a aucune
raison pour que vous me croyez mais
je tiens absolument à ce que vous
sachiez que ce que je vous dis c'est la
vérité et si je vous raconte ça chez un
ami c'est parce que quand je partirai je
veux avoir la conscience tranquille
j'ai eu beau prier dieu pour qu'il me
pardonne le fardeau installé là où mon
âme se trouvait autrefois devient chaque
jour plus dur à porter veuillez
m'excuser john je vais devoir partir non
vous devez vous reposer henry dans ma
chambre
dans ma chambre sous mon lit sous une
des lattes du plancher
il ya la preuve de ce que je dis
[Musique]
le pistolet de pistolet qui a servi à
tuer lincoln a été retrouvé dans le
théâtre john c'est ce qu'on dit est en
réalité j'avais 2 gold
en fait j'ai perdu le deuxième je
n'avais plus d'armes chargées
alors juste sauté sur la scène
j'ai envisagé le suicide et je voulais
mourir de la même arme que lui
[Musique]
accordez-moi cette faveur
s'il vous plaît allez chercher le
coffret sont moulées et détruisez ce
qu'il contient
accordez-moi la peine
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
nous
dr beats je crains qu'il ne passe pas la
nuit
c'est ce qu'il a dit il est clair que
son esprit l'abandonner
il a de la famille en ville une cousine
fanny rey 1 12 hommes pourrait-il
l'avertir moi je dois rester ici
[Musique]
je veux que tu ailles chez saint-helens
que tu soulèves toutes les planches du
parquet sous son lit si tu trouves quoi
que ce soit tu me le rapporte et signe à
rien tu t'arrêtes à la boutique de
vêtements étudiants fanny rey que son
cousin sur son lit de mort
oui monsieur aux écuries
il a foutu le camp
bon ça
tu le retrouves
et tu me le dis à lesquin
gordon
fanny rey a été la veuve d'un certain
william mode il ya plusieurs années elle
s'est remariée avec thomas serait vous
voulez vous revenir
j'étais ami avec william hague dans ces
années là
il a épousé miss missouri fanny booth la
cousine de saint-helens
il faut encore faire beau il n'y aucun
nuage dense et ouais il est bien mort
ouais attendant la preuve cette fois
c'est curieux on n'est pas entendu
parler bon voilà je résume la situation
on est là on n'a pas un sou en poche
personne chez qui aller qu'est ce que je
vais faire mon dieu
tout n'est pas perdu et j'ai quelqu'un
sur qui on peut compter
un ami ou comme ça comme ça je prédis si
ça s'est un peu plus loin là
le train de repasser dans une semaine
je vais repartir à dallas je vais aller
récupérer mes 300 dollars vous l'avez
dit qu'il était mort était abattu au
bowling par james hunt benson ils se
sont entretués [ __ ] il les aurait rien
à côté de l'autre
depuis combien de temps tu me
s'espionnent là j'ai tout entendu tu en
étais aux 300 dollars quarté cru
entendre du tabouret ou ziegler n'a rien
entendu rien je vais être réglo avec
vous j'allais te le prouver
tiens torture tout ce que tu mérites
c'est que je tentais revivant je veux
réparer ma faute je m'excuse sincèrement
pour la montre que les temps sont durs
pour moi aussi tu ferais mieux de te
tirer petit une chance que tu l'aies
parier sinon tu étais mort je sais que
l'on peut se procurer des chevaux
qu'est-ce qu'on les garde
merci il ya peut-être même moyen de se
faire du fric de quoi tu parles que
moyens qu'en face il a une famille de
fermiers kaeppelin de fourrure des
belles plus qu'il lui en faut on a juste
à y aller à servir il ya des chevaux
aussi j'ai vu tu veux compte des valises
une famille
quoi de qui tu parles et sur la regarde
juste à ce calme tu es bon ben oui les
banques on prend juste qu'il nous faut
pour survivre d'accord mais vite
[Musique]
à la chance a tourné cette fois c'est
bon et vous entendez un bruit sinon
ouais je te le dis ils allaient en vie
leur chariot aujourd'hui vous fait peur
tout seul
y a personne
on dirait qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
fredonne vous entendez pas n'en est rien
allez on continue c'est bien plus facile
que ce que je pensais
on devrait leur laisser
je veux pas qu'il se retrouve sur la
paille ouais il faut être fair pkk c'est
le truc route
et en plus d'offrir la marchandise
il nous fournit cette artillerie pour la
protéger il est chargé 3 bon ça nous
fait six balles à moudre et économise
les qualifs
j'ai jamais eu confiance en kelly dès le
début quand il m'a piqué masmonteil et
l'a rendue non parce que j'ai la
clémence de pâles transformé en passoire
durera très un bison dans un couloir
[Musique]
bon allez on va les chercher ces [ __ ]
de chevaux qu'elle y va les ramener et
doit être partie les chercher
[Musique]
bye
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'enfant de [ __ ] mais combien de
chariots horizons qu'ils étaient partis
en ville avec
voilà pourrir mais il ya quelque chose
de bizarre on nous valait morts
attention magheb histoire d'économiser
tu es mal mais je n'ai encore jamais dit
augustin attendez moi
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
pamela bach
par là
[Musique]
yamato monter dans le bateau tout
m
il
[Musique]
c'est votre bateau à thiès
aucune idée john et tu avais cartouches
ouais je suis prêt il faudra qu on les
rattrape à pied la végétation est
beaucoup trop dansé par anne-marie
prévenu m séries non maggie non je veux
que tu retournes à la ferme
il faut qu'il y ait quelqu'un tient
françois revolver aller dépêche toi et
vous vous allez au port il n'y a que là
qu'on les aura écoute moi bien si tu
vois quelqu'un sur nos terres
tu tires d'abord tu posera des questions
après ces compris c'est compris oui
allez en avant oui soit prudent jean
[Musique]
être hautement des drames et kelly je te
garantis que tu feras moins le malin
avec une balle dans la tête mac papa
j'ai attaché les chevaux à la lisière du
bois comme tu blagues marie duquel on va
les accueillir comme il faut elle vient
regardez ça attire ici on s'en sort
beaucoup mieux que ce que je pensais
on a intérêt à se cacher dans cette
forêt il faut pas rester sur le bateau
le trappeur va vouloir le récupérer
et en prime un poignard c'est vraiment
noël avant l'heure
il voit l' arbre couché dans l'office
ans visera juste au dessus
si on parlait business comment on va
partager tout ça au et bien on va
prendre tout ce qu'on pourra porter toi
tu récupères à ce qu'on laissera à moins
que je décide d'engloutir ta part de
whisky et reste à six oui il faut que tu
fais quelque chose au sujet de kelly ou
bien que tu verras son cadavre flotter
dans la rivière à tivoli gardens bien
j'attends calmez vous tous les deux tous
les deux tout est de sa faute mais
devait aller en vie voire gordon où tu
t'es passé qu'est ce que tu foutais aux
calmes on est malheureusement tous
dedans jusqu'au cou alors que ça te
plaise ou pas thuram
non
[Musique]
si on les influences
tu peux baisser ton fusil
et kelly ansa t'inquiète pas continuer à
jeter des pierres dans la rivière ok je
crois qu'on devrait aller à palau pinto
c'est un peu d'argent et même beaucoup
et que risky avec tout ça il nous
faudrait des chevaux abruti donne moi ça
c'est à moi pour celle de touche à sac
ça va ça va le shérif tout tombera
dessus à palau pinto s'est terminée au
cours plus après il y aura forcément
prévenu les autorités à quel jour de
gloire
quelle journée magnifique 1 il y à tous
les habitants de la république du texas
qui veulent que je me balance au bout
d'une corde et tout ça pourquoi n'existe
plus la république du texas au mais
qu'est ce que ça change
il me pendre ont aussi alors on fait
quoi on va vers l'est ce sera moins
risqué vers l'est
il faudra au moins deux jours avant
d'arriver quelque part et bien tant pis
on marchera le temps qu'il faudra
maintenant c'est à toi de voir
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya
j'ai entendu un bruit
pas encore du moins deux fosses reilhac
c'est le cas du bateau pourquoi tu porte
pas de colt crie ta joie de balfour
voulait qu'à la fermer et ben ont l'air
on vous tient en joue sortez la ensuite
du gibier il a dû traverser la rivière
mon dieu on a failli vous mettre au pied
ferme kelly on a failli vous expédier en
enfer vous nous avez foutu la trouille
les enfants ont retrouvé gibier on a on
a vu une biche qui traînait par là bas
quand empêchait devriez y aller elle est
bonne ça
pourquoi vous n'avez pas de canne à
pêche on a vu un bateau qui dérivait
voilà en fait on a ferré un poids sont
tellement grands qui nous a tout enlevé
et non même le bateau ils l'emmenaient
enfin ont failli me dit allez on a vu
des indiens il ya environ une heure en
amont rien à [ __ ] des indiens étaient
dix dont acer sa serviette à vue il
avait l'air méchant aller viendront
wei arrêté l'espionné tout le monde
comme vous le faites mais revenons à ce
que je disais le whisky en garde que
lima ok d'accord je vous laisse le
whisky mais les fourrures l on les
partage en trois lui maintenant on
trouvera bien un arrangement
bon en tout cas je vais pas rester sur
ses berges parce que ces deux vases puis
encore plus que kelly pas licite avant
dans cette famille d'accord toi tu ne
vis plus jamais de me dire ce que je
dois faire tu m'entends jamais on a
failli se faire tuer à cause de toi
trouillard greg craig
ouais mon whisky
bravo tu l'a effrayée mais reste muet et
pose ce fusil ouais mon whisky
je sais pas on n'a pas du ski ouais mon
bateau on n'a pas le bateau non plus
tenez prenez ça prenez le fis je vous
laisse de lui tient donne tenez tenez
prenez le repos ça on a trois écureuils
c'est tout ce qu'on a je vous assure
trois hommes vous les avez vus non j'ai
eu je voulais dire oui on a vu des
hommes
ils ont dit qu'ils avaient en bateau et
on l'a vu qu'il dérivait où c'était dans
cette direction à deux heures de marche
ils ont dit qu'ils étaient pêcheurs
cours
mais sauf toi
[Musique]
en
alors
en orange
c'est toi et toi t'es pas ma chanson
vous entendez les indiens des syndicats
y'a rien à craindre dans le coin ils
sont pas hostiles font du commerce de
peur les bijoux et de bouffe rien mangé
de la journée
on comprend ici ce soir je tiens pas du
tout aller rencontrer en pleine nuit je
croyais que tu avais dit qu'il n'était
pas hostile
ils ne sont pas en général qu'on avait
de gros problèmes avec les indiens sur
le chantier du train ils sanctuaire et
garder ce que j'ai trouvé bon dieu
t'aime sept mois ça trouver une pointe
de flèche dans l'eau ses portes voilà
pourquoi à cet intérieur kelly 1,7 fait
rire tu trouve ça drôle continuer le
massacre a plus le droit de blaye et
l'irlandais ouais mais bien les indiens
c'est pas de la blague la pitié savent
pas ce que c'est j'ai vu des choses
abominables des apajh dont il faut se
méfier mais y en a plus dans la région
et tous ses cuisses et hambourg c'est
quoi alors mais comme auch ils sont pas
dangereux doivent pas être plus de 4 ou
5 d'après le bruit écoutez le monsieur
je sais tout tu connais tous sur les
indiens ou quoi une fois qu'on aura
l'argent je crois que j'essaierai
d'aller en californie ouais
qu'est-ce qui en californie voleurs de
l'or il y a des tonnes d'or dans la
ville de baudis un business qui rapporte
gros à ce qu'on dit oh comment j'en sais
rien mais gros tout ça c'est du baratin
ouais qu'est ce que tu vas faire toi
alors qu'ils cherchaient de l'or c'est
une connerie je me disais que
je pourrais devenir un homme de loi
peut-être un homme de loi toi je suis le
shérif james mackinnon et voici le
marshall au wild world et lui c'est
dangereux bandits qu'on emmène dans une
autre prison à propos de shérif
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à grains de
riz vous êtes mes complices de jesse
james et qu'au lieu de vous démarquer
aux villes trempés jusqu'aux os sans
fric sans chevaux awel vous n'êtes pas
venu faire une petite balade un pas à
moi peu près pas croire que vous avez
rien à cacher tu te fais décidé on n'a
rien à cacher et bien sûr et c'est pour
ça qu'on allait s'enfuir à fond de train
on n'entend plus les tambours
quoi vous avez cambrioler une banque
c'est ça 300 dollars vous devez fuir
pour beaucoup plus que ça tu pourrais
pas oublier un peu ses 300 dollars si
ces têtes et oignons je comprendrais du
temps face mais c'est pas tes oignons
alors tu te tais je vais vous dire ce
que je vais faire je vais ma vallée une
bonne gorgée de whisky et louer le
seigneur de m'avoir laissé en vie écrit
tu vas aller prendre le premier tour de
garde
ça veut dire que tu me prêtes aux colts
non si tu vois quelque chose tu me
réveille et je ouvrir le feu aaaaaah je
mords de rien et garde tes m'a éloigné
de mes poches pendant que je puis
campion il faudrait montre
[Musique]
mais ton colts en évidence
je te rappelle qu'il n'est pas chargée
je veux pas que ces indiens pensent
qu'on dissimule des armes je croyais que
tu avais dit qu'ils étaient pacifiques
j'ai dit qu'il était sûrement sûrement
[Musique]
m
kerry sort quelques fous rires on prend
aussi le risque et non le whisky reste
là tant qu'on sait pas ce qu'ils en
intéressant les indiens c'est sur moi je
vais rester planqué là en cas de gros
pépin
allons-y irlandais a peur des méchants
peaux rouges alors c'est d'accord je
reste là je garde le whisky
[Musique]
non tout cela coûte
dans tout
[Musique]
bonjour
est-ce que vous parler notre langue un
peu tu as un visage donne qui a faim oui
si vous avez à manger on vous en sera
reconnaissant je m'appelle wind et lui
lit ses cris coach et n'a écrit rendre
hommes forts mois offrir à vous prenez
cette fourrure vous en tirer un bon prix
messieurs foire trois visages pâles
pourquoi ils se cachent
ne craignez rien et ce calme elle était
juste fatigué oui il a beaucoup porté
il a plein plein de choses à vendre je
vais aller je crois qu'il ya un problème
j'avais quoi nourrir toi oui merci merci
beaucoup c'est bien sympa
j'ai tué ma attaqué et je suis au
poignard je les déteste je les déteste
bonjour alors ces poissons hein c'est un
très bon en fait dit tu sais c'est
vraiment une bête magnifique votre
moulin vos chevaux où ils sont mes
chevaux bail sont morts parce que parce
qu'on les a mangés
non parce que mon ce que mon ami veut
dire en fait c'est que voilà nos chevaux
sont tombés malades et on a été forcé de
les abattre
on voudrait acheter votre votre mule
pour pour charger nos fourrure beaucoup
blanche est pas à vendre
on a des perles très belles perles à
échanger contre fourrure l' écoute grant
est on à me battre si on en veut on sent
vraiment très heureux de vous échangez
vos perrelet on a de bonnes offres à
vous faire plein de jolies fous rires
comme l'est en france c'est le moment je
crois mais aussi elle est magnifique
cette carapace de tortue joly c'est des
magnifiques perles bijoux très précieux
est belle marchandise vient dire moi
s'émerveille bon james
j'ai besoin d'un coup de main attends je
vais t'aider non ça ira que lui il vaut
mieux que que tu restes ici et que tu
racontes à ces messieurs pourquoi
pourquoi james a mangé notre cheval
c'est une drôle d'histoire vous avez
jamais croire on était au bord de cette
grande falaise qu'elle abat environ une
heure de marche et alors là vous
imaginerez jamais vous imaginerez jamais
sur quoi sert coire n'est tombée on
s'est retrouvé nez à nez avec une horde
de cougar bon alors on va faire comme
prévu tu vas tu vas chercher le ski et
c'est lui qui portait une fourrure
s'appelait c'était billy est un cheval
comme ça ira qualité l'histoire mais si
toi tu lis bien
alors le soleil commençant à décliner à
l'horizon j'aimerais partager avec vous
une bonne vieille coutume irlandaise
très chers amis indiens
on va troquer le whisky ouais mon proc
le whisky il faudrait bien que ce serait
votre ne t'inquiète pas ces nains ces
bouteilles renferme les flammes de
l'enfer et l'eau du paradis en buvant
cette eau de feu vous deviendrez perd 20
cibles guerrier bon au départ on croit
qu'on va mourir mais ensuite c'est noël
et pâques pendant toute la soirée
m
[Rires]
tenez c'est bon on en a plein d'autres
venir beaucoup 2009 et on va le voir
tous ensemble est un coup ensemble
en plus moi ce père qui les écoute moi
ça fait tourner
ça brûle les boyaux un gringalet bébé
allait mener sa rampe à mes amis whisky
[Musique]
on
tous
une autre nuit à laquelle vous aurez
survécu je vais du centre john
il faut que je mange quelque chose
bah
il ma sacoche qu'est ce qu'on voulait
[Musique]
allez vite pas que tu veux tu tires la
mule will
[Applaudissements]
fu fu les nourritures nos perles
pourquoi je n'ai rien volé fourrure
partie sommes avec toi
partez s'il vous surpris aller jouer à
gauche beaucoup bon effet le kala kato
conduit nos artères frère si l'on trouve
pas mais c'est rare omnium toi mon frère
[Musique]
oui
on va encore crapahuter longtemps comme
ça ce serait plus rapide en passant dans
le canyon par là facile à dire
c'est beaucoup trop raide
il faut qu'on revienne sur nos pas oui
si on rebrousse chemin on sera à
découvert et les comanches tout on est
trop chargé il faudrait peut-être
abandonné une partie du chargement ici
on fera des cibles trop faciles sur fait
demi tour
il faut atteindre ce canyon n'aurait pas
pu faire attention
[Musique]
je pense qu'on approche doivent être
prêts à temps
[Musique]
hachey
boîtier est abruti
oh [ __ ] t'es complètement stérile t'es
complètement cinglé si tu crois qu'on
peut transporter tout ça jusqu'à la
sortie du canyon sans que les indiens
nous tombe dessus
on va mourir si on tente le diable et
que tu m'entends il faut cousty rouil
ces indiens veulent nous scalper et toi
tu veut nous emmener vers les portes de
l'enfer
on peut porter ça c'est sûr fric
celui que m'a volé cette femme à dallas
j'avais dans ma poche depuis quatre
jours où ils seulement quatre jours je
l'avais voler un gars qui dormaient dans
le train quand je vous ai dit que je
travaillais dans les chemins de fer
je vole les passagers en fait l'argent
n'est plus là on m'a pris tout l'argent
mais tant pis l'essentiel c'est que moi
je suis encore là je m'en tape
tu comprends pas la situation laissait
tout ce qu'on a ici ce serait comme
jeter dehors dans un puits sans fond je
passerai ses portes de l'enfer avant
qu'elle 20e trucide et tueur frottant
ramasse ses paquets et partons d'ici
[Applaudissements]
tu n'as que trois balles dans ton
revolver il n'y a aucune chance que tu
te serves contre moi
m
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
et
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tant mieux
oui
à
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
à
et
m
[Musique]